the greatest abuse of the country that I
think I've ever seen financially China
what they've done to us is the greatest
single theft in the history of the world
they've taken our jobs they've taken our
money they took at everything we're
bringing our jobs back folks we're
bringing our jobs back that was from
last month the night of the South
Carolina primary with Donald Trump
riffing on one of his favorite targets
pipe turns out that a trump branded
tower in New Jersey is being funded
largely by a government program that
allows foreign investors mostly from
China to skip ahead in the immigration
line and get a visa and return for
investment it's totally legal although
if you spend your days and nights
railing against China it could be a
political problem joining us now on our
New York set with the details of this
story Bloomberg's investigative reporter
Jessi Drucker so Jesse first of all I
explain this program this visa program
called eb-5 and how it works so the way
it works is if you have half a million
dollars and you're seeking a green card
the US has a program where for
qualifying development projects if
you're willing to put a half a million
dollars into the project you can get a
two year visa that if kind of everything
works out with the project you will end
up getting what amounts to basically
permanent residency for you and your
family and what has happened the program
has actually been around for around 25
years it's really started to take off
and probably the last five or six years
and developers love it because it's
turned into basically a cheap form of
financing for high-end real estate
developments because the applicants the
folks that want the visa that are
putting up half a million dollars aren't
really that interested in getting a
return they just want to get the green
card and so what's happened in the last
few years is the government has given
out tens of thousands of visas through
this program and in the last few years
it's overwhelmingly two people from
China last year the government gave out
just over 10,000 visas and eighty-five
percent of them were two people from
China alright so this eb-5 program is
being used in connection with a trump
project in jersey tell us about the
project and the extent to which this
program is being
used for so a few years ago I think
about five or six years ago a developer
license the Trump name and built a
high-rise luxury condominium development
called Trump Plaza residents there in
Jersey City it's right on the water it
has incredible views of lower Manhattan
and two years ago jared kushner who is
the CEO of Kushner companies and is
married to donald trump's daughter
Ivanka announced that they would
essentially be building the sister
property a nearly identical 50-story
tower that will actually be luxury
rentals and this is going to be called
Trump Bay Street now typically Donald
Trump for the last 25 years you know has
actually developed and built very few
buildings he has built some but for the
most part his real estate business is a
business of licensing his name to other
developers this is some version of that
we don't exactly know what the financial
arrangement is between him and his
son-in-law but his son-in-law is using
the Trump name on the building that he
is building the financing for the
project a quarter of the financing about
50 million dollars is coming from the
eb-5 visa program in other words the in
other words the cushion her team went
out and found a hundred people I believe
they are almost entirely from China who
each put in half a million dollars and
essentially provided 50 million dollars
in loans to help build this building so
you said I think you just said it's
about a quarter of the financing of the
building given the politics of it why
take the money from China is it is this
the only place that this project can
find enough investment to be to build
well that's a really interesting
question them and I think one of the
reasons that the program is very popular
is because it's basically free money the
investors don't really want a return on
their investment they want the green
card and so where you might have to buy
a borrower from a bank for six percent
or eight percent or ten percent with
these investors you can essentially give
them no return so essentially it's like
getting a quarter of your financing for
no return now the reason the program is
of interest is both the Department of
Homeland Security and the GAO have
raised questions and concerns about the
inadequacy of the screening process for
figuring out where this money is from
and there are concerns that the program
enables money laundering and
jeopardize national security and there
two years ago I believe there was an
internal Department of Homeland Security
memo that Senator Charles Grassley read
on the Senate floor that raised these
very questions just a few months ago the
GAO followed up with another report
raising a similar question but just
because we got to go in a second we said
in beginning there's nothing illegal
obviously about this program and
although the optics from a political
point of view might be bad Trump could
argue right this is just good business
he's getting investment for a project
with his son-in-law that doesn't require
anything much from them and doesn't have
to pay the same rate of return as a
normal investor that's true he's raised
but he's raising money through a
government program that that basically
all government overseers of you is very
troubled and could be enabling a lot of
dirty money to enter the country